sometimes i get uh hate mail and
when we have that hate mail read by a
professional voice-over artist
we call it hatred mail here's a quick
reminder about that
why don't you take some hydroxic
chloraquin for that trump derangement
syndrome
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom all right let's get uh
there's a lot i'm warning you i would
get the kids out of the room there's a
lot in this week's hatred mail take a
listen to this
park man you're the most disingenuous
piece of [ __ ] on all of youtube go [ __ ]
yourself davey parkman commie
prostitute and panties loser
david parkman doucheboy wannabe
anti-catholic anti-american leftist
cannot tell the difference
between 100 mail in by voter roll
and ask for a mail-in ballot vote
my god how stupid are the leftist
dopes most damaging interview
what a clown loser this pompous
jerk is so a lot being said here
and a lot of it is is just wrong you
might be surprised to hear maybe not uh
i am
certainly not a communist you know this
is one of the funny things
it's actually similar to what's going on
with joe biden where with joe biden you
have
some on the left who are furious that
joe biden is not a socialist
and then you have much of the right
attacking joe biden
for being a socialist or a marxist or an
anarchist or a communist or whatever the
case may be
in that same way there's a whole
contingent
of the internet left that doesn't like
me they don't think i am left enough
because i am not a socialist and then at
the same time one of the most common
attacks we get from hatreds is
you communist socialist marxist david
pakman
um the truth is i'm just a social
democrat that that that's the very
boring reality
uh i'm certainly not anti-catholic i'm
not anti-american but what the what the
hatred does get right is that i am an
american leftist
that's true um and this is a trump voter
and you know we i keep getting calls
from people saying
how can i convince my trump supporting
friend
my trump supporting cousin my trump
supporting parents to vote for joe biden
i don't believe you can that hatred mail
is from a devout trumpist there is no
point
in arguing with them and trying to
convince them
with eight weeks minus a few days to go
before the election
to change their vote they don't care
about facts
they don't care about logic just get the
vote out from people who are on our side
we are better off we are more likely to
have an impact it is far easier to
convince people
who already agree with us that they
should vote than it is to argue with
someone like that and say no you're
wrong about trump you should vote for
biden it's an exercise in futility
it's an exercise in frustration what's
not an exercise in futility
is using the coupon code hatred
40 whenever you sign up at
joinpakman.com you will save 40 percent
off of the membership of your choice
with the coupon code hatred 40
and when that code is used i have it on
good authority that hatreds cry they
can't handle it
joinpakman.com coupon code hatred 40.